Transcription: Emmanuelle hardan
Relecteur: Anne-Sophie Matichard
J'ai décidé de rater mon bus.
Imaginez : une petite fille
qui se lève le matin,
qui va dans la rue pour aller à l’école
et prendre son bus.
Il fait encore un petit peu nuit,
puis elle retrouve ses copains
et ses copines dans la rue.
Tout le monde rigole, s’amuse,
mais à force de plaisanter,
la petite fille prend du retard.
Le bus passe devant elle.
Paniquée, la petite fille se met à courir.
Elle arrive in extremis devant le bus.
Elle toque à la porte et
le chauffeur lui ouvre.
Elle rejoint sa place, essoufflée,
Paniquée,
parce que sa plus grande peur,
c’est de rater son bus.
Sinon elle va devoir rentrer
dans la classe, en retard.
Traverser toute la salle, avec les regards
braqués sur elle,
jusqu’à ce qu’elle aille rejoindre
sa place, tremblante et rougissante.
Et ça, c'est son pire cauchemar.
Cette petite fille,
c’est moi.
Mais aujourd’hui, avec vous,
j’ai décidé de rater mon bus.
J’accepte d’avoir tous les regards braqués
sur moi
et de vous raconter comment
je suis passée d’une petite fille timide,
guidée par ses peurs,
à une femme qui accepte ses imperfections
et qui ose se révéler pleinement.
Vous raconter comment j’ai fait
de mes peurs une force
pour révéler tout mon potentiel enfoui.
D’ailleurs, à propos d’enfouir,
est-ce que vous connaissez
les matriochkas ?
Vous savez, ces fameuses poupées gigognes,
symbole de la Russie.
Peut-être y en avait-il une
dans votre chambre d’enfant ?
Moi oui, j’en avais, un petit peu comme
celle que vous voyez là.
Savez-vous que nous sommes
comme ces poupées russes ?
On veut montrer au monde la plus grande,
la plus belle.
Parfaite.
Zéro défaut, lisse, propre.
Et pourtant toutes les autres sont là,
à l’intérieur.
Elles auraient besoin d’être entendues,
écoutées, rassurées.
Mais à la place, nous les faisons taire.
Nous les enfermons.
Bien profond à l'intérieur de nous.
Parce qu’elles sont parfois sombres,
imparfaites, maladroites.
Il était une fois Perfecta.
C'est une petite fille timide
qui ne fait pas de bruit.
Elle est bien polie.
Elle dit bonjour à la dame.
Elle joue du violon et elle fait
de la danse classique.
C’est la bonne élève,
première de la classe,
qui ne dérange jamais,
la bonne copine, pas contrariante,
qui dit oui à tout.
Sa seule passion est la lecture.
Alors bien évidemment,
à force de lire des romans,
adolescente, elle rêve du prince charmant.
Le mariage, la maison, les enfants ;
enfin, vous voyez le tableau ?
Eh bien, c'est ce qu'il lui arrive.
Elle rencontre son prince
et tout se met en place
pour qu’elle vive sa vie parfaite,
comme dans ses livres.
Mais à votre avis,
est-ce qu’elle est vraiment heureuse ?
Non.
C'est l'illusion du bonheur.
Parce qu'elle ne s'aime pas.
Elle trouve qu'elle n'est jamais assez.
Intelligente, intéressante.
Vous savez, même se promener dans la rue,
c’est difficile pour elle.
Elle voudrait se rendre invisible.
D’ailleurs dans la rue -
vous voyez cette scène dans Matrix
où il y a une femme en rouge qui passe ?
Est-ce que vous voyez comment
tous les regards sont braqués sur elle ?
Et bien Perfecta, quand elle marche
dans la rue, elle ne voit que ça.
Des femmes canons, grandes,
avec de  longues jambes minces,
habillées en rouge
et que tout le monde regarde.
Et elle, elle voudrait tellement
se rendre transparente.
Dans son métier aussi, elle se cache.
Vous savez ce qu’elle fait ?
Elle s'occupe des autres.
Elle est assistante sociale.
Mais pas n’importe où, non !
Dans une école pour déficients visuels.
C’est pas un bon moyen
pour se cacher, ça ?
Sa vie est dominée par la peur de déplaire
et l’envie de bien faire.
Alors elle contrôle tout pour ne pas
se laisser déborder
et toujours garder le masque pour montrer
la belle image aux autres.
Bref.
Je pense que vous l’aurez compris,
je coche toutes les cases pour Perfecta.
L'illusion est parfaite.
Mais, comme dans tout conte de fées,
il y a un élément perturbateur
qui vient rompre la belle histoire.
Je comprends que mon prince
n’est ni charmant, ni un prince,
mais plutôt un dragon.
La relation est toxique.
Le prince et moi, c'est fini.
La claque !
Vous savez, c’est ce genre d’épreuves
que la vie met sur votre route
pour vous réveiller et vous sortir
de vos illusions.
Par la force des choses, je dois laisser
tomber le masque de Perfecta.
Pour faire de la place à Cramponia.
Et commencer un travail de
développement personnel.
Je comprends que je suis
dépendante affective.
Et comme j’ai peur de l’abandon,
je me cramponne
à tout ce qui me rassure,
et j’attire à moi des situations qui
se répètent : manipulation, abus, rejet.
Je commence à laisser sortir de moi
des émotions qui étaient enfouies
depuis si longtemps,
et c’est comme une digue qui lâche.
Colère.
Tristesse.
Honte.
Il en faut du courage
pour aller affronter ses démons.
Mais quand on y parvient, on peut laisser
la place à une autre des matriochkas.
Dulcia.
Dulcia c’est la douceur, la tendresse,
la bienveillance.
Dulcia elle vous aide
à prendre soin de vous,
de votre corps, à vous aimer pleinement.
Elle vient vous dire que
quelque chose d’autre est possible.
Quelque chose de plus simple,
de plus doux.
Et que si on arrête de se comparer,
de se critiquer et
de se juger aussi durement,
c’est comme une ampoule qui peut s’allumer
à l’intérieur de chacun d’entre nous,
à la condition de se regarder avec amour.
Et c’est en faisant sauter ces masques,
un à un,
que l’on peut voir apparaître Rebellista.
Rebellista, celle qui se rebelle,
qui ose sortir du cadre,
qui va faire autre chose que
ce que les autres attendent d’elle.
C’est parfois inconfortable
d’accueillir le changement,
mais quand on y parvient,
c’est tellement libérateur.
Et vous savez ce que j’ai fait, moi,
grâce à Rebellista ?
J’ose poser des congés à mon patron
le dimanche soir pour le lundi matin
pour aller suivre un stage
de développement personnel en Suisse.
À partir de maintenant, c’est moi d’abord.
Mais pour avancer sur ce chemin,
et aller vers la plus petite
des matriochkas,
il faut aussi libérer Harmonia.
Lâcher le masque de la contrôlante,
celle qui gère tout à la minute près,
qui organise, qui planifie son agenda
et même celui des autres,
pour aller vers plus d’improvisation
et de légèreté.
Lâcher la Wonder Woman qui veut mettre
le contenu de 48 h en 24 h seulement.
Tant pis si les tâches de la to-do list
ne sont pas toutes faites aujourd’hui,
ça attendra demain.
Bienvenue au lâcher prise
et à la légèreté.
Vous l’aurez compris,
c’est en ouvrant une à une,
toutes ces matriochkas,
que j’ai pu retrouver la personne
la plus importante de ma vie.
Certes, la plus petite
des poupées gigognes,
mais la plus précieuse à mes yeux.
Alexia.
Celle que j’avais enfouie en moi
depuis si longtemps,
alors qu’elle ne demandait qu’une chose :
s’amuser, rire,
croquer la vie à pleines dents
et être parfaitement elle-même.
C’est en acceptant nos imperfections
que l’on peut apprivoiser ses peurs
et se réaliser.
Je vous avoue que je pensais
que ce n’était pas possible
de sortir de ses peurs
et de ses conditionnements.
Et pourtant, je l’ai fait.
J’ai pu aussi m’épanouir et me réaliser en
créant mon entreprise
et j’accompagne des femmes à mettre
Madame Parfaite au placard
et oser se lancer à réaliser leur rêve :
monter sur scène, écrire un livre,
faire des conférences, voyager,
se mettre à leur compte.
Et je suis sûre que vous aussi,
il y a plein de rêves, d’envies
que vous avez envie de réaliser.
Je vous ai montré le chemin
que j'ai parcouru.
Et vous aussi,
vous pouvez suivre votre propre chemin.
Vous êtes capable de réveiller
la Michelle Obama qui dort en vous !
Nous nous cachons derrière des masques.
Il suffit d’en prendre conscience
pour arriver à les lâcher, un à un.
Faire ce fameux pas de côté.
Aujourd’hui, je n’ai plus peur,
ni des femmes habillées en rouge,
ni de rater mon bus parce que le bus,
c’est moi qu’il conduit.
Je pilote, je suis au volant de ma vie.
Et je sais que dans la vie,
tout est un cycle,
et que sur ma route,
je trouverai à nouveau
Perfecta,
Cramponia, Rebellista et toutes les autres
parce que nous sommes
en perpétuelle transformation.
Mais simplement, j’en prends conscience,
je les accepte, je les remercie
car ce sont elles qui ont gardé
la petite Alexia bien au chaud.
Qui l’ont protégée jusqu’à son réveil.
C’est en acceptant nos imperfections
que l’on peut s’aimer pleinement,
être soi même et se réaliser.
Et vous ?
Sur quelle matriochka êtes-vous ?
Quel masque devez-vous faire tomber
pour vous découvrir vraiment ?
Et surtout, qui est-ce que vous maintenez
bien au chaud ?